well I mean look what a geeks do we rank
stuff
[Applause]
so sort of my last bit of business I'm
relating to series 11 of Doctor Who I'm
gonna rank the episodes we've got if
you're wondering about this if you
didn't know I'd live in Vermont we're in
the middle of a cold snap I'm freezing
so um a little addition to the costume
that so yes I'm gonna take all eight
episodes of series 11 and give my
ranking of them from worst to best now a
couple things about this
I am only eeling with these relative to
each other so don't ya know realize that
this this is just within this season
I debated waiting for the new year
special to happen ultimately I decided
you know when I ranked series I don't
usually include the the special so I
decided not to wait for it and
ultimately it was we're kind of working
it out because what I came away with at
the end you know having broken these
down is that there are three episodes I
really like two episodes I really don't
and five that are either middling or I
have very mixed feelings about like good
and bad kind of canceling each other out
which I mean and the grand scheme of
things not the best percentage of the
world but there are there is stuff that
I legitimately got like ting you can
you'll print you'll tell when we get
there but let's get to it
so starting at the bottom number 1000
rack knits in the UK there was honestly
there was almost nothing I liked about
this episode I mean it just I didn't I
mean you know there was no well not okay
there was one thing that was nice but
there was a nice kind of creepy
atmosphere early on that's about yet
there was no there was no particularly
interesting character stuff going on you
know the fact that it's going to be
spoiled by the title alone so there's
only so much tension even that decent
atmosphere could give you the
explanation was cheap and cheesy for
what they were and why were they why
they were there especially considering
this is a show with large spiders as
part of its history and you went with
nuclear waste and then genetic tampering
mutations and and then there's the all
God the character that Chris Noth plays
I Oh God
he was so pointless and pointed he was
very obviously making very specific
points but they didn't contribute to the
episode like I don't have a problem with
character who's largely there to you
know make some sort of point as long as
that point is one that it's
strengthening a larger point being made
by the episode and this episode like
plot wise is largely just a filler
episode and then they plunk this guy
down in the middle of it oh god it hurts
did not like this one at all going up
from that number nine the Saranga
conundrum now this one I didn't actively
dislike as much as arachnids in the UK
but this one is aggressively mediocre
like aside from the fact that as I as I
mentioned in almost every episode it
looks good for the most part one
specific thing there is almost nothing
that is that stands out about it that is
particularly good about the only thing
that I liked was I kind of liked the way
the the the chief medical character was
sort of pushing back and challenging the
doctor a little bit but then he's gone
from the story and you don't then we
don't have that anymore and the whole
thing with the patanè which a stupid
name
beyond that you know this like it looks
like stitch it's and then it's this
little thing that's doing a ton of
damage and is really dangerous and like
I mentioned this in my review and more
than a few people in the comments really
well no but sometimes I can happen in
the contrast is interesting I'm like
it's interesting on paper the execution
doesn't work
because the way it feels to watch it is
it feels like the actors weren't told
what it was going to look like and it
feels like they are reacting to
something that looks much more dangerous
than this thing actually looks so it
just creates a disconnect and it's just
one more thing that didn't work in an
episode that like I said I aside from
the Petain which I can point to as a
flat-out fall down none of the rest of
it just really does much it's just kind
of there it's it's the epitome of filler
but unlike good filler there's no
shining thing in it to raise it a little
bit it's just flatlined filler so go in
from that we get to number eight the
woman who fell to earth now I don't
actually actively dislike the woman who
fell to earth there's actually a pretty
big gulf between my number nine and my
number eight but this is how they landed
and while I did for the most part enjoy
this episode and liked it well enough
even going back and revisiting it having
seen the the series finale it just
doesn't have a lot that clicks with me
for whatever reason it it just I don't
know it this one's really hard for me to
nail down why it doesn't quite work but
it just it doesn't it doesn't get me
there right off the bat it feels very
much like a setup and I mean that's part
of the thing which is that it is it's
setting up new doctor and three new
companions plus you know that new sonic
screwdriver and all this stuff all at
once and it it again a little bit like
the sarong a conundrum nothing's really
getting the proper chance to shine
because it's so much loaded in like if I
were to make a comparison and I think
it's a it's a valid one to make to the
eleventh hour which also a crap ton of
stuff to establish right off the bat cos
new doctor new companion you know new
status quo no holdover characters or
anything like that it managed to have
the doctor and the campaign shine
because it was laser focused on that
relationship and that
like here there's focus on you know Ryan
and Graham and Graham's net and you know
grace then on their dynamic and we get a
little bitty-ass and then here's the
doctor and like it doesn't coalesce it's
like it's a bit of individual moving
parts but the like it's almost like
they're moving independent of each other
so going up from there we get the number
seven we get to Rosa now Rosa I you know
I did I did two videos reviewing Rosa
because four things relating to you know
my own life and my own sort of issues
that I deal with in the way I look at
the world and stuff going on at the
moment it the episode on first viewing I
thought was decent and then but
something didn't sit quite right and
that sat worse and worse and worse as
time went on then once identified what
it was I did the second video I'm I'm
actually a little bit nicer on it now
than I was when I did that second video
I haven't turned around but like my
feelings on Rosa as an episode are
complicated I admire what it's trying to
do and I would even say that for the
most part it does it well there's just a
few things about it that for me
personally with with my values and stuff
that I deal with wait on me in a bad way
um one thing that I will retract from my
second video that I did on this episode
is that I kind of wrapped that video up
by saying maybe they just shouldn't have
done this episode or tried to do this
story because I don't think Doctor Who
is equipped to do what they were trying
to accomplish I am gonna retract that
because again limiting it to the
conversation that had in my own comments
section I don't know how about it was
elsewhere this is why I don't venture
out into other into other areas of
fandom all that often but I did really
appreciate the conversation that
happened so even if ultimately I feel
for me that Rosa doesn't quite work I
really did appreciate the conversation
that you folks had that I got to have
with you about that about what it was
doing so for that reason I no longer
feel that dark
who shouldn't have done it I still do
feel that again for my part it doesn't
quite work all right so then we get up
to number six and that is the witch
finders now the witch finders goes along
pretty well and does decently basically
until we get the IV identification on
the mud monster aliens and it's really
rush towards the end it reminds me a lot
of power of three in that respect where
it's got a set up and a premise that you
know it builds around and it does a lot
with and then once we identify what the
alien threat is that just gets crammed
into this tiny ass you know space of
time and it just it doesn't do it any
favors so but you know there there is
good stuff in here I think the the
general build up until we get you know
more about the alien menace is done very
well I think Alan [ __ ] is quite good
I did really like the speech that the
doctor kind of has you know directed at
him when she's you know kind of tied up
and and so you know there is good stuff
in here it just kind of falls apart a
little bit at the end so moving on from
there we have number five the ghost
monument which I did enjoy a pretty
decent amount but on a rewatch I've
recognized that a big part of my uptick
from the woman who fell to earth was it
just it I it felt more like what I
wanted a regular show a regular episode
of Doctor Who to feel like if I actually
try and break this episode down into its
component parts it's not doing much and
I can't say that there's actually all
that much about it that's all that great
other than just to say that for me it
just felt right I liked the feel and the
vibe and the of the episode overall and
that kind of glossed over some things
that were not as strong as they could
have been but there is a fair bit that I
like here I actually really like the guy
who's running the contest I like here
that sort of aloofness he has to him
that
that made him really interesting sort of
almost villain not quite villain kind of
character I was enjoying you know the
what was going on with with the doctor
in terms of that desperation that moment
of in front of her getting in front of
the TARDIS was really nice because I for
whatever reason I like it's super
obvious and hind set for whatever reason
I didn't call that the ghost monument
was gonna be the TARDIS so you know
seeing just seen the flickering image of
the tires I was like oh so like there's
little moments like that that just do a
little bit to boost me along through an
episode that I think is decent so moving
on we get to number four and that brings
us to hold on let me see if I can say
this right the Battle of Rance kun AB
colos yeah these names chip no come on
so the series finale which has a fair
amount of decent stuff in it some of
which actually pays off things that
weren't properly built so like I like
the villain Tim Shaw here way better
than I liked him in the woman who fell
to earth and but the thing is that I
feel like he there needed to be better
done there or we needed another
appearance of him somewhere in the
middle because I feel like we're getting
a buildup and a payoff to a villain who
is not build up as much as the episode
is pretending like he's built up but it
had mark addy which is always a good
thing for me I finally clicked with this
doctor and got a sense of who she was I
was like oh okay so I finally had my
moment we're like I get you yes yes you
are the doctor
like literally it was the very last
thing she said before going the TARDIS
had talked about going down to the wire
but you know that that was nice to
finally see and finally feel and I also
quite enjoyed Graham's moments both his
you know his sort of determination and
the threat of him going dark and then
also you know the
likeness of him like you shot it well
only in the foot I like I liked that
that was a lot of fun there are hiccups
and I talked about them in my review I
like I'm getting to the more positive
end of the list so I don't want to dwell
on them too much but yeah there are
little hiccups little things little
little bits in the way the story was
told that I'm like there had to have
been a better way to do that or that
wasn't necessary or I don't like that
trope but overall it does work for me so
now we're gonna get into the three that
I do legitimately like just like and
this is not something that they're
perfect episodes but I don't really have
reservations about these last three so
number three herbal I am feel wise in
terms of the feel and the vibe and the
movement and the momentum of the episode
this is what I want to be the standard
in Doctor Who and I feel like this is
the vibe that most episodes should have
because it is a fun fast-moving
adventure with a little bit of mystery
and in in a cool interesting location
and that setup is just that's just great
Doctor Who to me that that is a setup
that works really well I really like the
doctors enthusiasm I like Ryan's sort of
immediately oh yeah I know what working
this kind of gig is like you know Graham
has some nice tender moments I know I I
don't know if it was a tum but I know
some people took issue with the villain
either as a character or sort of his
motivation and like how that may have
muddled messaging for the for the
episode of what it was trying to say I
get that but even like thinking back on
it I'm like I still really like it and
this is something that I've said before
like if if messaging that I even if I
take on board you know the the version
of sort of the subtext that some people
have gone for and I'm you know it may be
writers certainly if it's what you took
from it then it's valid for you
absolutely but like for me and not only
did I not quite go there but even if I
do like I am kind of of the of the
disposition that
well if good and test intentions and
messaging I agree with don't save a bad
product because they don't then there's
only so much I'm gonna hold core
messaging that I disagree with again
something that I think is really good I
mean that's not to say like everything
gets pass if it's you know I'm not yeah
I'm not gonna be seeing the praises of
the original birth of the birth of a
nation film because like that was
atrocious
messaging but yeah there's wiggle room
there for me but that's me I did I did
really enjoy this I but I had fun that
was my big thing with curb-link ker-blam
was fun so moving up we get into number
two demons of the Punjab I think this
was though the episode that had the most
emotional resonance for me personally
and there's a number of reasons for that
but I mean it part of it is sort of
relating it to my own relationships with
older members of my family and feeling
like I don't know their stories as well
as I could or probably should and sort
of seeing that play out it and feel that
sense and then I mean this is the one
episode where yes I think does actually
get shine as a as a companion because I
think she was very badly underused I
feel bad for you as a character because
I feel like if she was the only
companion I'd probably like her a lot
but the show doesn't seem to have a lot
of use for her but she gets she gets
nicely focused here and it's focused on
an aspect of history that I genuinely
knew almost nothing about and found
fascinating in a slightly depressing
manner because it it wasn't pleasant but
I thought it was well presented I
thought the guest characters were were
well done I thought what was going on
with the aliens turned out to be at the
end of the day fairly interesting as
well the doctor is a little bit of a
passenger in this episode it doesn't
feel like there she has
all that much to do which doesn't
automatically make an app so bad there
are good you know dr. light episodes but
fur from my part I still felt like I I
was I had been waiting like to get to
know her and so to see her put on the
back burner before I had that moment
that gave me a little frustration and
that's probably the one reason this
didn't take the top spot because like I
said this one had the strongest
emotional resonance for me but I'm gonna
end up giving my top spot too it takes
you away this one was interesting
because I you know when it was over I
was like that's weird and I think I
liked it
but yeah it was one of those initial
reactions that at a later date could
have really gone either way coming away
from it and thinking on it and
revisiting it it could have been a case
of no I actually don't like it was just
so weird I didn't know how else to
process it or it could go I I not only
do I like this I really like this which
is what it ended up being it was fine I
didn't make like the mental connection
but more than a few commenters compared
it to Douglas Adams which I think is
probably a big part of why I really
liked it I think the reason I think lock
that in my head was because I I
associated to us that I'm so strongly
with humor and it's not an especially
funny episode um you know a couple
little moments a couple little things
but it's it's it doesn't have the same
above humor behind the absurdism it's
more just bizarre but then I thought
about it like this is kind of very
Douglas Adams - the humor and wordplay
flourishes that he would tend to do all
over his work so yeah that that again
sort of seeing that and more than a few
people said that I'm that goes like oh
yeah maybe that's why he worked so well
for me so yeah that's that was my that
was my favorite episode of series 11 and
that's not just by Camaro I think that
was a genuinely great episode of Doctor
Who
I get why some people don't like it it
is weird it is a weird
episode but it was precisely my kind of
weird so that's why it's my pick for the
number 1 episode so since this is just a
ranking of series 11 whatever your
thoughts are for your favorite your
least favorite or if you want to write
the whole series go for it I would
appreciate if you just wouldn't if you
wouldn't show up in the comments just a
dunk on the series and go they were all
crap like let's if that's where your
mind sets at I'm not saying you have to
lighten up like I'm sorry you didn't
enjoy it but like let let the rest of us
try and have a little fun
ok there's been a lot of trolling going
on lately and I'm not I'm not a fan my
block list is getting along
I don't like adding to it so in any case
whatever your thoughts were on series 11
ranking your best your worst the whole
thing whatever you want to do drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff you
can do because there's buttons and links
including one to my patreon if you feel
like supporting me that way it would be
a really big help and if you don't want
to check that out that's okay there's
other links down below as well
Twitter and link to my book my Pio boxes
down there
somebody asked during the last
livestream you don't want to look at any
of that that's okay too because you know
what and at the end of the day you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]